all right we're moving on now we're on
to Marvel Studios Black Widow big game
spot one day I will recruit a female to
be in a black widow trailer reaction not
today we got Pat the Canadian with us hi
everybody
anywho why are we wasting more time
let's watch this 30-second spot
[Music]
in the auction
taskmaster juice
[Music]
do Florence Pugh I Liza's lover man i
watch little woman recently and I'm just
all about all about Florence Pugh as of
late
David harbors just gonna kill it a
minute I've talked so much about this
already that you have not put your
thoughts online as it yet so why don't
you take it away I just it's I'm just
gonna repeat what a lot of people have
to say but Marvel has a lot to kind of
prove weirdly with this movie one that
it feels like this movie has come a
little bit too late in terms of what
Black Widow means in terms of what you
know Captain Marvel came out on the
right side regardless of just this is a
movie that one is a smaller scale film
coming after endgame it's kind of
starting the template of what is marble
going forward whether it's more
experimental along with their Disney
Plus shows yeah I'm kind of doing what
we all know what Scarlett Johansson can
do if like leaving a film but it's
interesting that there's this family
aspect to it especially with a character
that is so isolated in whether it's her
backstory her personality and everything
it just seems like this movie is doing
its best at least of the marking that
we've seen to branch out intimately with
a character that has carried over as a
legacy character since Iron Man 2 and
I'm just very curious as to if this is
good and as it says this film is not yet
rated I don't think Marvel's gonna make
a radar film with Black Widow but it
feels from what they've presented it
feels like how ready and ready a little
bit more just let's hone in on intimacy
of seeing Florence pew David Harbor
ilysm Rachel Weisz of just this is about
relationships this is about it's about
the past but it's about making sure that
if we're gonna deal with the past we're
gonna have to deal with the people that
come along with and it's that intimacy
that I'm really excited to see Marvel
take forward going for these faces I
mean it seems like even we're just
having that one line overlapping of you
know the Avengers weren't my first
family there's a lot about my past you
don't know that they're like no guys
this is important all right or not just
ran
we doing this this is an essential film
as part of the Marvel Canon okay and
like echoing a lot of the things I said
in the last special look they gave us I
mean taskmaster looks and awesome and it
really seems like yeah family will be a
big theme but the heart of the movie
will be between Scarlett Johansson and
fleurs pew John quick thoughts while
other things are dropping as we're
filming oh yeah man I mean I'm pew crew
to the core love florins Pierce and I'm
just really excited for the cast I think
most of all in this I mean having
obviously Scarlett Johansson
Rachel Vice horns pew David Harbor in
there I like the ensemble they're
building together and yeah this does
look like a more espionage image movie
for them which excites me I mean for
Marvel it does remind me of far from
home in the sense that people were like
you're gonna cap off your big like
franchise culmination with this random
little like sequel to something that
feels a whole lot smaller and because of
that I have a bit more fate in this
movie despite it's weird timing because
we can all agree this probably should
have happened you know five to eight
years ago
I mean maybe when we watch it that will
be like it actually makes sense
perfect because I could see that
potentially happen I feel like David
Harbor especially will bring a lot of
gravitas but also a lot of humor ballet
and he's just great at balancing both
think you're gonna have the most screen
time black groggily I'm just confused
like that they kind of made a change
that he doesn't have the horns anymore
and he's not ready and I'm like I'm just
the earliest comic accompany definitely
there yeah I just if they're gonna have
this interconnected universe I like some
constant here Moe del Toro is the new
runner for Marvel Cinematic Universe and
it's solid today all right guys what do
you think of this big game spot but it
kind of remind you the Fast & Furious
something a little bit more yeah but
still the little glimpses we got it I
love this just any shots with the cast
just gets me really excited specially
like the insomnia not as ended but I do
love that David Harbor alright guys will
subscribe click that notification bell
and keep a lookout for more to come